[Musica]
Avete presente quando fate una scoperta
che cambia completamente la vostra
visione delle cose come quando leggete
un libro che vi apre la testa o
Viaggiate in un posto lontano Ecco
questa cosa mi è successa di recente
ascoltando musica un tipo molto
particolare di musica a dire il vero che
non avevo mai sentito nella mia vita e
che oggi si trova prevalentemente dentro
agli archivi vi va di ascoltarne un
pezzettino forse all'inizio non vi sarà
chiarissimo però farò del mio meglio per
spiegarvi è un canto di lavoro solo voce
senza musica sotto
sentite signora R non
[Musica]
ma
a
[Musica]
Che
bello Ecco questa voce che sembrerebbe
provenire dal Medio Oriente in realtà è
registrata nella mia città a Palermo
negli anni 70 è il canto di un
fruttivendolo una bagnata eseguita in
una modalità Antica Le cui radici si
perdono nel tempo ora questa
tecnicamente ha un nome si chiama musica
di tradizione orale ed è quel repertorio
che i popoli si sono tramandati di
generazione in
generazione così senza testi scritti
spartiti tutto a voce tutto a memoria
Cioè voi vi siete mai chiesti come si
faceva quando non c'erano i dischi cioè
come faceva la gente umile il popolo
cioè Qual era la musica nel mondo
rurale possiamo dire che questa era una
componente molto importante Si cantava
da soli o Insieme soprattutto durante il
lavoro o anche durante situazioni
rituali Cioè se noi
immaginiamo di fare un viaggio nel tempo
e volare in mongolfiera magari basso
soprattutto tutte le case della Sicilia
drizzando le orecchie sentiremo insieme
al cinguettio degli uccelli alle cicale
al cane che abbaia al rumore degli
attrezzi da lavoro al Fruscio del vento
anche l'uomo che canta tutto il tempo
naturalmente senza palchi e senza
microfoni la musica Il canto aveva una
funzione diversa era immersa nella
quotidianità nel rito nella preghiera
nella laoro era lamento magico e
sacro In poche parole questo che abbiamo
appena sentito È espressione musicale
nella sua forma più primordiale Cioè
come il lupo ulula anche l'uomo ha il
suo verso ed è il
canto ora vi vorrei far sentire un altro
estrat Dino molto piccolo di un canto di
carrettiere in una registrazione molto
preziosa perché e ripresa in un Fondaco
questa Locanda siciliana dove i
carrettieri Si riunivano e si sfidavano
in gare di canto sentite questo signore
come Modula la voce come la fa
[Musica]
vibrare
[Applauso]
ma dei
carrettieri Ecco questa modalità di
canto così ricca di dettagli come le
fiancate pittate a mano dei carretti
siciliani è stata tramandata nel
palermitano per secoli e secoli a voce e
ancora oggi per fortuna qualcuno a
Bagheria canta così ora devo essere
sincero All'inizio ero un po' scettico
si devi fare un po' l'orecchio a questi
canti
però la cosa mi incuriosiva e così ne ho
ascoltati parecchi e ne ho scoperto una
varietà infinita soltanto in Sicilia
Cioè ve ne potrei F ascoltare a migliaia
canti di
carrettieri limonari tonnaroti mietitori
salinai contadini lamentatori della
settimana Santa e chi più ne ha più ne
mette e ognuno di questi contiene intere
culture sommerse cioè pensate che
soltanto lungo il 800 I ricercatori
hanno iniziato ad interessarsi a questa
materia e hanno fatto spedizioni sul
campo per raccogliere questi canti chi
ne raccoglie 3000 chi ne raccoglie altri
1000 inediti un altro 5000 un repertorio
sconfinato che ha un canto per ogni
occasione serenate ninna nanne canti di
amore gelosia spartenza sdegno uomo la
tua donna ti tradisce Vai sotto la sua
finestra e la canti una bella serenata
di sdegno avvelenata attraverso la quale
puoi declamare a tutti le sue bruttezze
una hit FR tante Affacciati in finestra
o shimonita Affacciati in
fin Ecco era questo il repertorio che un
tempo
[Applauso]
Grazie era questo il repertorio che un
tempo tutti conoscevano e
cantavano io non avevo mai sentito
niente del genere Cioè più parlavo in
giro di questa musica più mi rendevo
conto che le persone intorno a me non ne
sapevano nulla Mi sembrava di aver
scoperto il nostro Blues sepolto in
fondo agli archivi di aver scoperchiato
il vaso di Pandora e questo nostro Blues
era vivissimo ancestrale ipnotico
Brutale ascoltavo queste voci e mi
vibrava il
sangue però non assomigliava molto
all'idea che avevo della musica
siciliana ma forse perché fin da bambino
ero stato abituato ad una versione
edulcorata
folkloristica della tradizione
soprattutto durante queste recite di
fine anno a scuola elementare mi ricordo
me stesso bambino in mezzo a altri 30
bambini con la coppola il fazzoletto
rosso il gilet e il flauto dolce
facevamo le melodie di vittina Crozza e
ciuriciuri ora dico sospendendo il
giudizio su queste canzoni però noi ci
sentivamo un po' ridicoli eravamo
bambini di borgata nella Palermo degli
anni 90 non ci poteva essere un'estetica
più distante da noi sembrava appartenere
a un altro popolo ad un'altra
generazione ed effettivamente quella
cosa ha sancito proprio un disinteresse
totale per il mondo
popolare e in effetti
se ci pensiamo bene quest'idea di
tradizione in costume ne presuppone
un'altra che forse non fa tanto bene
alla tradizione e alla sua vocazione che
è quella di essere presa rimodernata e
trasmessa ossia tradizione uguale
passato e in quanto tale va preservata
perché è importante non perderla noi
tutti siamo abituati a questa idea di
tradizione no ma invece è vero proprio
il contrario cioè Siamo noi che abbiamo
bisogno della tradizione e e che ci
preservi la tradizione per non
disperderci è questa la funzione
antropologica della tradizione nelle
comunità fornire loro un orizzonte
condiviso di riti canti ricette lingue
modi di dire proverbi usi attrezzi
costumi eccetera eccetera eccetera per
compattare le comunità per unirle C è un
autogol totale Se smette di
rappresentare la gente e inizia a
rappresentare se stessa in un quadretto
mitico fermo nel tempo le comunità hanno
sempre avuto bisogno di tradizione
musicale per definirsi per dirsi chi
sono e e quando non ne hanno una a
disposizione che sia loro intorno Ma non
gliene frega niente Ne rubano ne
adottano delle altre tipo senza andare
troppo lontano a
Palermo così come altre città della
Sicilia mi hanno detto anche qui si
canta Il neomelodico
napoletano dico altri si rivolgono al
Blues alla musica brasiliana a Rock and
roll all'elettronica
mondi bellissimi ma tutto questo
denuncia un vuoto a livello
radicale e allora perché non rilanciamo
e diciamo
tradizione uguale presente l'arancina è
tradizione ha la sua storia bellissima
lunghissima pare che Fu inventata dai
cuochi di Federico II per le sue battute
di caccia al Parco della Favorita Va
bene ma io non ho bisogno di conoscere
questa storia mi mangio l'arancina e me
la godo mi piace mi nutre mi
rappresenta è che mi devo mettere il
costume di Federico II andare a caccia a
cavallo di faggiani per mangiarmi
un'arancina nessun Cantore presente
negli archivi portava un
costume
Oh questo concetto mi sembra che sia
chiaro però rimane il mistero di fondo
di tutta questa
storia perché la maggior parte di noi
questo repertorio non lo conosce non
l'ha mai sentito perché in Sicilia
esisteva un repertorio così condiviso di
musica popolare e da un momento
all'altro non esiste più che cosa è
successo alla nostra identità musica
Dov'è finita quando e
perché per rispondere a questa domanda
dobbiamo fare lavorare un attimino il
cricetino e immaginare questo mondo
contadino che ha il suo modo di
funzionare le sue logiche i suoi canti
da secoli secoli e secoli laddove non
sono millenni che a un certo punto si
trasforma radicalmente
in che cosa dire voi nella società dei
consumi Ora io sapevo che questa cosa
era avvenuta a un certo punto della
nostra storia l'ho studiato a scuola
seconda rivoluzione industriale arriva
il progresso e patapim e patapam però
non mi ero mai reso conto che in Italia
sta cosa inizia negli anni 50 cioè ieri
mia mamma è degli anni
50 e allora proviamo un attimino a
immaginar cela questa Italia del secondo
dopo guerra completamente distrutta e
traumatizzata dopo due conflitti
mondiali è un paese ancora
prevalentemente contadino che ha
un'unità da quasi 100' anni ma che in
realtà non è unito ancora non ha
un'unità né linguistica né culturale ed
è su questo paese che arriva la bomba
del Progresso il boom economico come
tutti sappiamo col Boom arrivano le
televisioni e davanti a queste
televisioni davanti a questi schermi
televisivi finalmente L'Italia si
unifica tutti a guardare questo schermo
che propone un modello nuovo d'Italia
fresco
benestante urbano con l'appartamento e
il lavoro in città
l'elettrodomestico naturalmente davanti
a questo modello di benessere i
contadini che venivano dalla miseria più
estrema non vedono l'ora di farne parte
lasciano le campagne si dirigono di
Frette furia in città e in campagna
lasciano quel mondo secolare di cui i
canti erano spina dorsale per la prima
volta sono il consumo la pubblicità che
orientano i pensieri delle persone per
Paolo
Pasolini usava parole molto forti per
descrivere questa trasformazione
antropologica ne sottolineava tutta la
violenza dicendo che si trattava di un
genocidio
culturale capite Cosa
significa per fortuna prima di questo
genocidio culturale dei ricercatori sono
andati sul campo con i primi microfoni
portatili a riprendere queste voci e tra
questi occorre citare Elsa gugino e il
folk studio che sono i curatori del
materiale sonoro che stiamo ascoltando
oggi e se da un lato queste tradizioni
iniziavano a perdersi dall'altro
iniziavano ad essere edulcorate e
rappresentate per motivi turistici
televisivi discografici commerciali i
gruppi in costume di cui sopra sono
figli di questa onda ad
esempio Incredibile No questa radice che
aveva attraversato secoli millenni senza
mai perdersi era stata
spezzata spezzata
o
congelata cioè perché non consideriamo
questi archivi come delle Celle
criogeniche dove questa cultura è stata
ibernata per poi essere scongelata
decenni
dopo quel mondo è andato perduto
naturalmente ma noi abbiamo queste voci
che ci raccontano ancora in maniera
molto profonda chi siamo da dove veniamo
E questa cosa è fondamentale per
rimanere uniti compatti in un mondo che
ci vuole sempre più spaesati dispersi
soli perché non proviamo a seguirla
questa radice e vedere dove ci
porta Io dico che ci porta all'acqua ed
effettivamente io una sorgente l'ho
trovata vi spiego ero da solo in casa e
stavo ascoltando distrattamente dei
documenti sonori ero proprio agli inizi
della mia Ric Cerca
e stavo sbrigando nel frattempo le
faccende niente all'improvviso si
illumina tutto parte quel canto di
fruttivendolo che vi ho fatto sentire
poco fa la
bagnata mi si apre il cuore mentre
ascolto questo fruttivendolo che mentre
canta gioca con ironia con le signore
con le quali
mercanteggia mi metto a piangere mi
scende addosso una sensazione di
dispiacere fondo per questa musica così
bella che era mia ma nessuno mi aveva
consegnato come un'eredità lasciata in
sospeso da qualche parte di cui non
sapevo nulla ne avvertivo tutta la
perdita così da quel momento ho deciso
di accendere il cambiamento che avrei
voluto vedere la tradizione che si
incarna Nel presente e si lancia
tradizione uguale futuro
innovazione altre persone
incredibilmente stavano maturando le
stesse cose dentro loro stavano facendo
gli stessi pensieri avevano le stesse
esigenze che avevo io e ci siamo messi
insieme abbiamo fondato un collettivo
che si chiama l'ero l'ero studiamo
impariamo
riarrangiato per restituirli alle
persone e vedere che cosa succede nella
convinzione che se non ti piace la tua
tradizione nelle rielaborazioni che ne
sono state fatte nel corso dei decenni
puoi andare alla fonte all'ingrediente
grezzo all'essenza di quello che siamo
l'archivio
Oggi tutti
noi facendo vibrare queste voci ancora
una volta facciamo un gesto di
riappropriazione
collettivo di una parte della nostra
cultura di questa eredità che non ci è
stata mai consegnata da una storia
crudele ascoltando queste melodie AB
beveri una radice che è eterna e che
canta oltre il tempo e lo spazio da
sempre e attraverso noi stasera per
sempre
grazie
[Applauso]
i